l'incubateur de saint quentin en
yvelines va rentrer dans sa quatrième
année d'existence depuis 2010 est le ski
cuba a accueilli 41 porteurs de projets
qui ont abouti à la création de 16
start-up un bilan plutôt positif pour
alexandra rosetti la vice présidente en
charge du développement économique à
saint quentin en yvelines
si jamais simple de créer et de lancer
une start up dont quand on a travaillé
quelques réussites ça que ça aboutit on
est on est que tout content de 2,6
chiffre-là et le ski cube rentrer dans
une seconde phase de développement avec
de nouveaux services proposés
d'abord le développement et
l'approfondissement des expertises
apporter aux start-up accueilli et
ensuite le renforcement du programme
d'accélération
on écoute à nouveau alexandra aux roses
et et qui nous détaille ces dispositifs
c'est un accompagnement plus poussées en
matière je suis en matière juridique en
matière ressources humaines en matière
financière c'est à dire qu'on va faire
appel à un éventail d'intervenants
extérieurs un petit peu plus poussé pour
être techniquement plus précis on va
dire
l'autre volet c'est l'accélérateur qui
lui va permettre on va nous permettre
d'accompagner des entreprises qui sont
créées qui sont déjà maintenant sur une
vraie dynamique mais qui ont besoin
d'être soutenue en termes de
développement commercial en termes de
relations commerciales voient même voire
même en arrivant à se tourner vers
l'étranger
autre nouveauté le ski cub souhaite
aussi s'ouvrir aux start-up étrangères
l'objectif de cette seconde phase
permettre le développement de 27 heures
par an et ça commence dès maintenant
avec la nouvelle campagne d'appel à
candidatures lancé le lundi 2 novembre
si vous avez un projet que vous
souhaitez le développer en vous
installant au ski cube pour bénéficier d
accompagnement et bien vous devez vous
rendre sur ce site internet vous pourrez
télécharger le document de candidature
remplir les différentes informations
demandées et vous avez jusqu'au 3
décembre 2020